can a 350 TV actually be good yes very
good and that is because this Toshiba
m550 isn't actually a 350 TV or at least
it wasn't at first I believe that this
is the best TV you can get at that price
point by far and I'll explain exactly
why and why I went to Best Buy and I
bought this model when Toshiba reached
out to us and they wanted to Showcase
their TV lineup now as you guys know we
get thousands of emails and I have
turned most of them down because of
their products but this TV right here
came out about a year ago for eight
hundred dollars and now it just dropped
to 350 dollars and it is an amazing
steal now to be honest I am a TV snob I
have that huge 4K projector system in my
basement I bought TVs that are six seven
times the price and I bought TVs that
were twice as expensive but we're not as
good for five main reasons and the first
one is image quality so many TVs out
there are 4K but the difference is
massive and this TV actually has local
dimming up to 48 zones which is unheard
of at this price point that means
instead of like the cheaper MacBooks
where you have a gray screen when you're
watching Dark content especially at
night you have much deeper blacks
because part of the screen can
completely shut off its back lighting
and that greatly increases the contrast
and makes the highlights really pop in
particular for HDR this makes the image
much more Vivid it makes it pop and all
the processing is done with toshiba's
rexa engine 4K Pro which was designed
and tuned in Japan as I mentioned this
is a 4K TV so you have a lot of detail
but with that Toshiba is using their AI
4K upscaling to bring 1080p content even
1080p gaming to look much better are
bringing it up to 4K and it's not just
over sampling or simply replicating
every pixel and intelligently detects
the colors of neighboring pixels and
decides the proper color in a detail and
texture that you should have to give you
near 4K quality with that it supports a
wide color gamut of over 90 percent TCI
P3 which means it offers much more
colors than a conventional LED TV to
give you finer color variations and it
gives you more color depth with richer
Shades now that is especially important
for HDR content which could be 10 bit to
make it look like it was intended to
look and with that it supports not only
HDR 10 but also HDR 10 plus and Dolby
Vision so you're covered on all of the
fronts now certain applications will
support Dolby Vision while other ones
like Amazon Prime video it supports HDR
10 plus so you really want to have both
of these and with that if you're
watching a regular HDR that isn't smart
HDR well they actually have a function
that's called 4K gradation correction
which in real time corrects luminance
and colors to give you a great looking
HDR image even if the signal is not
proper an HDR rest duration that can
bring some of those highlights back down
so that it will look its best and
because of this no matter what kind of
signal you're washing it does look good
on this TV instead of Cheaper models
that can be very flat or have highlights
that are just out there where it's pure
white where an SDR image wouldn't have
that issue and now with that this TV
also has really wide viewing angles
because the front panel is really nice
same thing with the LCD panel so if
you're sitting on the side it still
looks good and you probably noticed that
the bezels are very slim on this TV most
budget TVs will have really thick bezels
because it's cheaper but because this is
a much nicer one and the price point has
come down you get the super slim bezel
all around which makes it look nice and
clean and modern and it's less
distracting from what you're trying to
watch it also has ultimate motion 120
hertz which is great for games that will
smooth everything out along with sports
and with that you can actually dive into
the menu and you can turn it off for
things like watching movies if you want
it to run at 24 frames per second and
you have a lot of different settings so
you can adjust how much the dynamic tone
mapping and other software options are
using to get the best image that you
like and for gaming and sports there's
dedicated modes that can easily optimize
for that and the game mode can turn on
automatically which will reduce latency
now other than the picture quality
there's some other reasons why this TV
really stands out and the first one is
sound it supports multiple dolbys
including Dolby Atmos and DTS which
means that the sound is optimized and
for most TVs that are at this price
point the speakers really suck this one
has really powerful speakers that
surprised me with surprisingly good bass
because once again it wasn't designed as
a 350r TV go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
foreign
the next thing that really stands out
and surprised me is the build quality
when I took it out of the box I was
happy that they had great padding all
around so you're not touching the
display and the build quality is really
great the main top portion of the back
panel is solid metal and then the bottom
portion is high quality plastic and we
do have a vase amount built into the TV
and not only that but the legs
themselves are made out of metal they're
not plastic and where they install the
whole frame portion of that is also
metal instead of being plastic for other
TVs at this price point and it also has
a bunch of inputs we actually have a lan
Port Optical out a headphone jack as
well as a USB port four hdmis including
Arc and some Legacy connections and one
thing that I really appreciated is that
the legs actually have cable management
built in to there so you can route your
cables without them hanging off the back
or having to use tape now this TV also
supports Bluetooth and Dual Band Wi-Fi
so you can have a fast connection and
not only does it come with the Fire TV
smart remote but it also comes with an
IR blaster that you can connect to it
just in case you have it hung up so that
you can get a proper signal Now setting
this thing up was incredibly easy
because it does use Fire TV I was able
to use my smartphone to connect to my
Amazon account and I was just logged in
that makes it very simple and then I
could select the additional apps that I
want to use because it's a smart TV and
it just downloaded and installed it
automatically it also comes with a basic
mode if you don't want the full
experience but switching to the full
mode you have access to live TV
thousands of channels of course it runs
Alexa so if I say it right now you guys
see that it pops up right there and so
you can use it as an Alexa device to
have things show up on it and that is
very very handy you can control your
smart home and the remote also has a
microphone built in so I could just say
open Amazon Prime video and it's going
to pop up and open up that app without
me having to go home and navigate
through all of that now if you don't
want to use the remote or like what
happens at my house the kids are using
it gets misplaced it gets lost well the
microphones are far field so it can hear
you from a further distance and if you
have music or kids in the background it
can still hear your voice so I could say
Alexa play peripheral on Prime video and
Bam it is playing that show even though
I never played it on this TV yet I was
playing it at home so everything is tied
in with the Amazon Fire TV setup now
along with the apps that I mentioned we
also have the free channels which you
can watch free TV of course you can go
in and you can download other apps and
applications and because it's tied into
Amazon you have Amazon music I have my
photos which I back up there you have an
internet browser and you don't have to
use the apps that are built in of course
you can stream to it including being
able to use airplay so if you have a lot
of Apple devices like I do you can pair
it up one time and then be able to play
your content like I have Dave Lee
playing right now his new laptop video
or other things just like screen sharing
photos and things like that now Toshiba
TV is actually running a giveaway until
December 18th to celebrate the FIFA
World Cup there's only a few steps that
you guys have to do to enter to win an
Amazon gift card and all of that will be
down below along with the link to the TV
so overall if you're looking for a TV
that is not expensive and one that's
going to have an amazing picture with
really good sound and great smart
features you cannot beat this Toshiba
m550 I like the 15 inch 55 inch size
it's going to be going to my basement
when that is remodel build and set up
and you guys go ahead and check it out
using the links down below click above
to subscribe check out our other videos
right over there that's been Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]